so next next we have Steven Crowder so
um a little refresher on Stephen Crowder
um Crowder went viral a couple of months
ago because honestly Crowder was the
type of guy that did everything right
he's pro-marriage Pro family
um I believe he was a virgin when he got
married um and he got married young and
he had kids isn't known for cheating
whatever
um and a couple of months ago it came
out that Crowder is getting divorced
um and as much as I do love Candace
Owens I do I really I am a fan of
Candace I do think she got this run
wrong Candice shared a clip on her
channel of crowder
um being emotionally abusive towards his
wife and on this channel if you've been
watching for a bit we know that all of
these terms emotional abuse coercion
sexual assault those are all feminist
words they were all words invented in
the last hundred years to basically
incriminate men and call a lot of basic
behaviors predatory
um so this clip came out of crowder
you are not taking a car because if you
refuse to write for things then I will
go
snakes would pellets my grill
I know it's not a reasonable request
s
how about you first
how do you wish
I'm a man
would you like me to ask right
give him an Uber
okay Stephen I can't
feeling some constraints like I can't
see it like listen to me listen to me
you want to walk out right now listen to
me I can't go to the gym I can't go to
my parents I can't call my friends I
can't go I can't be home you're gonna
take the car and leave me here Hillary
just think of how boxing has made me
what do you need me to pick up I'll get
it I'll be back when I'm back
it doesn't work either
[Music]
the only way out of it is
yeah yeah there you go you throw your
hand you give up so easy
you give up so easily I just said the
only way out of this is discipline or
respect you should remember
okay I love you but Stephen hear a piece
and sick
watch it sit watch it
watch it
okay
I need some space we need
you
I love you very much
I don't love you that's the big problem
I've never received love from you and
the fact is when I go look I need to do
a b c and b just be just fund out if you
go now what I love you more than life
itself okay
Hillary you're right right
someone
isn't it
worthy of a life worth no matter the
life
Hillary Hillary come on now I'm not
gonna engage I'm not gonna engage
anymore I'm gonna go I'll get text me
what you need I'll get you the TV
bye
I love you
I'm committed to you
have some lunch
I'm I'm not into I'm not trying to do
those things you're not committed to
anything you're not committed to
anything
all right
are you committed enough to get the
medication
so it's funny it's funny because when I
watched this clip I just had a
completely different reaction it's so
interesting when you re-watch these
clips with like a red pill lens because
my first thought was why did she have a
clip from like two years ago she must
have been like sitting on this two we
don't know what she did to start the
situation and three my thought was like
you're you when you get married you're
supposed to obey your husband
so if she just obeyed him that whole
fight if she just said okay that whole
fight would have been avoided and the
fourth thing I noticed was she was using
again you know the the feminist terms
your abuse is sick Stephen and he's like
I'm gonna let that go
um like I just think we're kind of at a
weird place in the conservative movement
if we're calling like a fight between a
couple abuse like I just didn't see
abuse in that
um and I just I guess I have a different
point of view on this from interviewing
so many men
um that have been victims of divorce
really that have been divorce raped and
what I've noticed is like a lot of women
will put Clips out of context to make a
guy look bad so when I see like Clips or
texts get leaked
um I'm just a bit more skeptical because
you know there's two sides to every
story and uh and this
you know my question is why were you
sitting on a clip from like two years
ago and the other thing that made me a
little skeptical was like them saying
emotional abuse I'm like really and the
third thing again I was I just kept
thinking I was like if she just if she
just listened to him and didn't take the
car and just got the Uber
um it would have been fine and that's
why a lot of times I really put the
arguments on the woman because you know
again we when we get married we're
supposed to submit to our husbands and
what does that means that means to obey
when your boss tells you something you
don't go back and forth arguing with him
and if you do that's usually the
employee's fault
um you know so if she just listened that
whole thing would have been avoided but
the problem is we've had a hundred years
of propaganda and most women that are
married today have never been told that
their role is to obey their husband
um so recently in the Crowder court case
there was a clip that came out of the
nanny actually admitting to lying but
and this is another Trend I've noticed
like women will work with each other to
basically destroy a guy's reputation
um and I noticed this trend when again
when I was interviewing guys that had
been divorce raped and a lot of them
um basically texted their friends
talking about how they were trying to
get the guy to abuse them so they could
bring it into court and then get the
kids so you know I'm not saying she did
that but but I've seen this before and I
also think as women we just have a
natural like tendency to over exaggerate
things and just you know they like kind
of view the past with a lens of just
like being the victim I I don't know why
um so now we have a leaked video shows
Crowder's nanny is admitting to making a
false statement in divorce during the
swarmed sworn deposition in the third
paragraph of your declaration you say I
was surprised
by Stephen barging into the house
wearing a body camera I see that
sentence
yes
so were you surprised that he quote
barged into the house or were you
surprised that he was wearing a body
camera
maybe the camera I don't recall which is
more surprising
well you authored this didn't you
yes wouldn't you know what you meant
um this is the best of my recollection
I understand that ma'am but I'm asking
you when you wrote the words in your
handwritten notes that Mr Nelson turned
into this declaration were you surprised
about barging into the house were you
surprised about a body camera
both neither don't I mean what what did
you mean by this phrase
counselors or something funny
she's answered your question Council
and when it's your turn to take a
deposition you can take it the way you
like
but I don't need I don't need you to
laugh
unless there's something funny and you
want to tell me what's funny objection
form thank you
what was surprising ma'am both things
all right
um and you say that he barged into the
house do you still stand by that
description
to the best of my memory
all right well in the prior deposition
you were shown the video from the GoPro
camera right no I saw about three
minutes of it and then it broke and then
and and
in fact ma'am the truth is that he
knocked on the door rang the doorbell
camera the ring doorbell and you
answered the door
right yes
well I'm going to show you what I've
marked as deposition exhibit number 39
there's a PowerPoint
in your notebooks Council
are you can you see the screen here all
right I'm going to play this for you
can you make that
[Music]
sorry man
did you see that clip yes do you need to
see it again no
you answered the door correct right
after he'd rang the doorbell and knocked
correct yes
what about his actions In that clip were
barging
well I can see now that my perception
was different okay so you don't stand by
the word barging
correct
today I don't all right misperception of
the events yes all right
and there there it is folks that's the
thing like women we just over exaggerate
everything
we really do and we have this like
defend The Sisterhood at all costs
um as like our gut reaction
and it's really interesting because
Crowder has said he's under
um I forgot what it's called but it's
basically an order where he cannot
publicly talk about the case yet Hillary
went out and publicly put forward a clip
of crowder and ham from inside of his
home and this is what happens all the
time guys I interview guys that like I
interview men all the time that this has
happened to where the women will go on
social media they will go to the school
they will ruin a man's reputation and
the man is under a court order that he
cannot defend himself and yeah I just
think it's wrong and when I saw this
clip
my gut reaction a couple years ago
probably first would have been to
believe Hillary but you know now that
I've really interviewed a lot of guys
going through divorce now that I've seen
a lot of like patterns in divorce
um you know women that claim emotional
abuse usually it's
um you know women that claim coercive
control it's usually like
and women that publicly put out
information about a guy trying to make
him look at look bad
um it's usually because the
women that actually have gone through
stuff
typically are not crazy loud about it
um you know that's just my experience
but I will say we we do have to wait and
see until all the facts come out but
that's just like my gut reaction to this
case from the beginning but yeah um this
is why I say guys we have to be really
skeptical when we have women come out
with stories because honestly I think
our natural inclination is just to over
exaggerate things and when we act like
men and women are the same and are
equally as credible
I I just think it's dishonest because I
just see the difference between a
woman's point of view on a story and a
man's point of view on a story and just
typically the man's point of view tends
to match reality more
um but maybe I'm crazy maybe I'm just
the big old sexist I don't know let me
know in the comments also guys let me
know what you want me to react to
tomorrow
um I am back from vacation so you know I
am going to be doing more episodes of
pearl daily
um like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel and I'll talk
to you next time